it didn't take long did it kept afloat
by a good start a nicely placed plot and
some UFO table magic let's say demon
slayer broke through the barrier that
keeps anime series niche and transcended
into the realm of pop culture and online
memes as we end the year many of us are
eagerly awaiting the movie that will
chronicle the demon train Ark following
up one of the series that I'd consider a
breakout hit in 2019 as we rev up for
the upcoming movie we're here to relive
some of the epic and dramatic moments of
fights in Demon Slayer now I don't want
to keep you waiting so let's just get
started we start off the list with the
opening scene the first episodes often
the most important in anime is where you
draw viewers in and make sure they stay
for the ride now in my opinion the first
episode of Demon Slayer does that our
hero comes home to a nightmare seeing
his family slaughtered by demons is
something that would surely haunt anyone
for years to come
what's worse the only survivor naisu co
awakens as a demon just as tan Jiro
tries to carry her to safety with his
own sister attacking him due to her
demon instincts tan Jiro is saved by
Tomioka resolving to kill naisu KO as
she's turned into a demon Tomioka is
stopped by tan Jiro who immediately gets
knocked down by the superior Demon
Slayer it's right after the unthinkable
happens seeing her brother fall mizuka
moves in not to kill him but to protect
him from Tomioka it's a new development
for demon Slayers
seeing a transformed demon somehow
retain her familial instincts new Zuko's
a special exception and this leads to a
possible breakthrough and pushes our
hero to the start of an epic journey to
transform his sister back into a human
the final selection boss fight deserves
a spot on this list and it finds itself
at number nine one of the key moments in
most Shonen anime is the first battle
where our protagonist
unleashes his soon-to-be mainstay power
the first Rasengan getsuga tensho and
release of one for all our iconic
moments in their respective series and
of course Demon Slayer is no exception
facing an uphill battle due to his lack
of experience Tan Jiro finally makes his
breakthrough in this life or death fight
his reckless attacks are ineffective to
the demon after a suspenseful battle tan
Jiro releases his water surface slash
cutting through the demon and finally
avenging berroco Ducky's fallen students
hey gg
in eighth place we have moose ons first
appearance it goes without saying that a
series villain has to make a lasting
first impression
one look at moose on and you already
know that he means business Michael
Jackson jokes aside moose on looks the
part of an intimidating and menacing
main protagonist said to be the
originator of all demons he actually
comes as a surprise that he was
introduced as a direct counter so early
in the series he had short screen time
then but we immediately get to see what
he's capable of blending in seamlessly
among the crowd of people he shows off
his capability of creating demons doing
so right in front of our protagonist
just as suddenly as he appeared moves on
escapes detection but we're sure that
he'll be popping up to confront our
heroes sooner rather than later for now
a hero has a long ride ahead of him
next on the list is the battle against
the swamp demons for his first mission
tan Jiro investigates a local town
that's being plagued with mysterious
kidnappings it doesn't take long for the
culprit the swamp demon to reveal
himself
however the kidnapper demon isn't alone
in actuality there's three of them now
faced with a numbers disadvantage it
seems that the newbie Demon Slayer is at
his wits end that is if he fights loam
but it turns out he's also not alone in
this battle enter his little sister no
Zuko whom he spent the past couple of
episodes protecting no Zuko joins the
fight and helps protect Kazumi allowing
tan Jiro to go on the offensive it turns
out that his little sisters also a
capable fighter in her own right the
pictures and previews have been teasing
it so it came as no surprise that this
moment cementing a Zuko is one of the
key fighters in the Demon Slayer team
and will remain in a lot of fans minds
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
first impressions last forever and if I
were to give Zenit Suh a score for his
first one it wouldn't be a good one
that's not to say I don't like him it's
just that he gets introduced as the
staple goofy comic relief as you've
learned from Shonen anime though under
estimating this type of character can
have dire consequences he immediately
gets his time to shine in the arc he's
introduced him inside the drumhouse the
cowardly demon slayer spends his time
running from the tongue demon after
getting trapped by the demon Zenit Zoo
is terrified to the point where he
passes out when all looks doomed then
it's who gets up in a trance in which he
unveils a badass technique of his own
the Thunder breathing technique and
kills the demon in one attack all while
asleep
beware the goofy ones indeed
[Music]
among the earlier fights in the series I
think the fight that features the kymaro
siblings and Tamiya and ushiro taking on
two of muslins assassins is the one that
sticks out having found unexpected demon
allies it's then that an assassin breaks
through the houses invisibility
technique and engages in battle now the
battle begins
Anton Jiro is on the defensive against
the numerous balls being thrown at him
it takes a while before he finds the
source of the balls pinpoint accuracy a
second assassin that's been guiding the
projectiles with arrows thankfully he's
got Anna Zuko on his side to go after
the other demon finally giving him some
breathing room to reset the fight after
a hard battle the siblings defeat the
two demons only to find out that they're
not even members of mu son's elite
demons despite their strength overall it
is a nice fight though and also features
the cool moment of naisu ko playing
kumari with her opponent that also
reveals that Tangier owes little
sister's been growing even stronger on
her own as time goes by
[Music]
coming in at number four is the battle
against the spider demon mother Don
zeros group are greeted by an unpleasant
sight at mountain Atta Gumo they
discover that demon Slayers have been
mysteriously attacking each other inside
the forest even coming under attack
themselves now it doesn't take long
before in no scale locates the source of
the problem
a spider demon that has the ability to
control others like puppets the battle
also allows 2 and 0 to get to the
demon's mother and finish her off with
water surface slash as the spider demon
mother dies she warns tangier oh that
one of the 12 demon moons moons elite
demons is on the mountain this fight is
a good way to start the new work battles
against puppeteer type enemies are hard
to write but this ones of the right leg
has enough twists and developments and
shows off the power of the town zero in
no skate tandem if there's a fight that
gets the audience height for the next
phase of an arc this has got to be one
of the better ones
number three is mooses massacre at the
end of the anime series personally I
consider the mountain at aguma arc the
true climax of the anime
what follows is mostly an art for the
characters to wind down and take a
moment tree brave from the next major
set of battles even then the functional
recovery art gives us a memorable scene
featuring Mouzon and his demon
underlings Musa makes one more last
appearance before the end of the series
in the form of a woman
citing Ruby's death moves on decides to
disband the lower order of his elites
what follows next is something I didn't
see coming instead of just disbanding
the order of demons moves on slaughters
them with the exception of n Mook seeing
potential in n move moves on spares the
last remaining lower moon what a cold
blooded bad boss indeed as for Andrew
though this is definitely not the last
you'll see of him watch the upcoming
movie to find out
[Music]
continuing with the countdown we take a
look at the appearance of the Demon
Slayer pillars in mountain at ogumo
sensing that something's gone amiss in
the mountain two of the Demon Slayer
elites get sent to mountain at ogumo one
of them is a familiar face Gyo Tomioka
and he's flanked by a female pillar
shinobu Cacho they intervene in the
mountain at ogumo events and make an
immediate impact she no but makes her
way west and saves the poisons in itsu
showing off her beautiful and graceful
battle techniques in the process as for
Tomioka though he encounters inno skate
and saves him from another spider demon
confirming that the enemy that he knows
K's been struggling against isn't even
one of the twelve moons he sidelines the
hot-headed boar as he moves on to deal
with the greater threat himself
obviously this appearance wouldn't be
the last we see of him in the arc it's
fortunate for tangiers group their help
in the form of these elites is on the
way as I'm positive the group would have
been wiped out without them
[Music]
finally triumph being as the number-one
moment in demon slayer is the climax of
the ruie battle what else did you expect
to be number one now I doubt a lot of
scenes in the anime can match what many
consider the crowning highlight of the
entire adaptation few scenes claimed to
be the one scene that catapulted the
series past the hump and the climax of
the battle against Ruiz one of them it's
a scene that not only sees tan Jiro
unleashed the final form of water
breathing but also unveiled dance of the
fire-god
that along with naisu KO unlocking her
own demon bladder turns the tides on the
seemingly infallible ryu backed with
godly animation and music this scene
made one hell of a statement pulling in
the attention of the entire Internet to
this cool new show and making fans out
of a lot of us
[Music]
she's not
and with that we end the list if it was
good reminiscing about one of the epochs
of 2019 doesn't it the anime made me
read the manga and I'm surprised by a
lot of the future developments that the
series has installed here's to getting a
second season after the inevitable
success of the movie are there any other
key moments that you feel should have
made the list feel free to make your
thoughts know through the comments
section leave a like if you enjoyed the
video I'd really appreciate it and I'll
see you next time on Binney tube
[Music]